spider-man homecoming as the Spidey
reboot fans have been waiting for and
it's positively crawling with Easter
eggs and connections to the
web-slinger's previous appearances on
the big and small screen the Marvel
Cinematic Universe plus references from
over 50 years of Spiderman history in
the comics yippee-ki-yay movie lovers
it's Jen here and there are so many
Easter eggs in Tom Hollands first
spider-man solo movie within this video
I'm going to focus on the toughest to
spot and best Easter eggs and references
you might have missed I've also got some
very cool Funko pops leather pack of
spider-man homecoming merchandise to
give away for a chance to win make sure
you subscribe turn on your notifications
and leave me a comment below about your
favorite Easter eggs or any others you
spotted just before I start quick
warning there are spoilers ahead for the
movie so take care if you haven't seen
it yet
homecoming director John Watson said he
took a lot of inspiration from the
original spider-man comics and there's
one iconic issue amazing spider-man
number 33 that features prominently in
the movie at one point in the film
vulture uses his suit to collapse the
warehouse trapping spider-man under a
ton of rubble and girders the way
spider-man gets out from under the
rubble motivated by reflection of
himself and the voice of Tony Stark is
similar to how Peter visualizes Uncle
Ben in the comic and uses that as a
source of inner strength to help him
lift the rubble off himself and
eagle-eyed fans might also remember
there was an immersion this same iconic
comic book issue in Captain America
Civil War when Spiderman was weighed
down by an airport walkway that Captain
America smashed onto him Michael Keaton
may not have read any spider-man comics
before bringing to life the classic
villain vulture but the movie still has
a very cool Easter Egg to his comic book
character on the Staten Island Ferry
there's a car with a license plate SM
2-0 5 6 3 in other words amazing
spider-man issue to publish may 1963 a
comic which features the first
appearances of both vulture and the
tinkerer who is a character who makes
vultures Tech in the new movie the
Staten Island Ferry event also tips its
hats the fact that in the comics the
birthplace of Adrian Toomes
aka vulture is Staten Island and
although the look of Michael Keaton's
vulture is quite different to his comic
book counterpart the costume designers
of
they deliberately added a straggly fur
collar to his jacket as a nod to both
the feathers on a real vulture and the
original vulture designed by artists
Steve Ditko homecoming introduces the
villainous shocker to the MCU and is a
settler Marsh to his yellow diamonds
patterned costume in the comics via the
sleeves on the jacket worn by the first
shocker Jackson Bryce and later the
second shocker Herman Schulz also has
them sanal glitters character Aaron
Davis tries to buy some tech from
shocker
and later spider-man interrogate him in
a car park to learn more about what
vulture and his crew are up to Spidey
suit analysis on Davis reveals his alias
is the Prowler a nod to his comic book
alter-ego and during the interrogation
Davis mentions he has a nephew in the
neighborhood in the comics Davis is the
uncle of Miles Morales who like Peter
Parker was bitten by a radioactive
spider turning him into a famous web
crawling superhero
this Easter Egg works on several levels
firstly Sony have an animated movie for
multimers in the works
secondly the nephew mentioned suggests
that Mars Morales could also exist
either in the MCU or Sony's live-action
spider-man universe and finally it's
interesting because donald glover and
his fans campaigned for glover to play
spider-man before the character's first
movie reboot and later that led him to
voice Miles Morales in the ultimate
spider-man TV series SCI demand
homecoming very obviously connect to the
MCU with the opening scenes reliving
moments from Captain America Civil War
from Peter Parker's point of view but
there's a less obvious call back to an
earlier MCU movie that I particularly
enjoyed now during this early fight
scene with a group of criminals breaking
into some ATM their masks very obviously
evoke the Avengers but there's a more
subtle joke and reference you may not
have noticed the Spidey takes the thugs
out at one point he makes Thor punch
Hulk which is a night reverse of how
Hulk smashed through at the end of the
Battle of New York in the first Avengers
movie by the way given the criminals are
wearing Avengers masks I also like the
identity theft joke here in the
background when happy Hogan is arranging
the move of Avengers tech like Tony's
help us to armor from age of Ultron and
a prototype of Captain America's new
shield he also mentions something we've
not yet seen in the MCU that is Thor's
magic belt the north' name for which
happy gives up trying to pronounce
the belt is also known in the comics as
a belt of strength or the power belt and
it gives the wearer incredible strength
I wonder whether the belt is just a son
Easter egg or whether it's something we
might see in a future movie for example
Ragnarok or infinity war the callback to
the first Captain America movie at the
end of the scene on Coney Island when
the camera pans up to the cyclone
rollercoaster in that First Avenger film
just before Steve Rogers and Bucky zips
wide down to the Hydra train carrying
Zola they reminisce about how Steve
threw up on that same roller-coaster
ride when they were younger in
spider-man homecoming actor Kenneth Choi
returns to the MCU this time as
principal Morita Choi previously played
the role of Jim Morita a member of the
Howling Commandos in the first Captain
America movie and as a clever Easter Egg
to his previous role with a picture of
Jim Morita and the principal's office
suggesting the two men are related by
the way this isn't the first time Marvel
is reused actors for new roles in the
MCU alfre woodard had a minor role as
Miriam sharp in Captain America Civil
War where she confronted Tony Stark as a
mother of a son who was killed in the
battle of sokovia then later that same
year she had a much larger role as the
villainous Mariah Dillard in the Netflix
series of Luke Cage and Martin star who
plays teacher mr. Harrington and
spider-man homecoming previously cameoed
in 2008 The Incredible Hulk as a
computer nerd who is said to be Amadeus
Cho in the movie novelization spider-man
homecoming really delves deep into the
capabilities of Tony Stark's spider-man
suit and after Peter and Ned hack into
the suit to remove the training wheels
protocols we next discover that the suit
is also equipped with an AI voice to
assist Peter with the suits functions
Peter calls the suit lady program Karen
and she's actually voiced by actress
Jennifer Connelly who played Marvel
character Betty Ross in director
angley's 2003 Hulk's movie a pre MCU
movie released by Universal but what's
even more interesting in a sort of MCU
in joke is that Jennifer Connelly is
married to Paul Bettany who played
Jarvis the original voice inside Iron
Man's suit before he became vision in
Avengers age of Ultron after Ned learns
that Peter is the real spider-man he
starts asking him what power he has
for example whether he can summon an
army of spiders this is a curious
question because spider-man did indeed
use that threat against a villain in
issue 57 of Marvel Adventures spider-man
and when ned suggests that peta should
go and stand on the edge of a building
and see how far he can shoot his web it
immediately made me think of the first
Sam Raimi spider-man movie where Tobey
Maguire's Spidey literally does just
that and he's learning about the extent
of his abilities there's another fun
amage to that first Sam Raimi movie and
the kiss the web crawler shirt with Mary
Jane as he hung upside down after
rescuing her during the Washington
Monument rescue in this film was a
moment where spider-man is hanging
upside down after he's just saved lives
from the plummeting elevator Spidey suit
Lady Karen even says this is your chance
Peter
kiss her in a nice callback to his
upside-down kiss with MJ back in 2002
and earlier on roots Washington through
the road sign warning about the
Triskelion cleanup the Triskelion is a
shield headquarters built on Theodore
Roosevelt Island and this mentioned by
the road sign is a link back to the
events of Captain America the Winter
Soldier where the Triskelion was
severely damaged when one of the project
insight helicarriers
crashed into the building in the movie
finale spider-man homecoming introduces
the Department of damage control
properly in the MCU although you might
remember that the organization appeared
on a news report ticker playing in the
background during the very first Iron
Man movie and also got a mention in
agents of shield in the comics damage
control is an organization initially
owned by Tony Stark and Wilson Fisk and
founded by Anne Marie Hogue who's played
by timed alien homecoming where she has
a very similar look to her comic book
counterpart interestingly Marvel
actually announced the comedy TV series
called damage control back in 2015 it's
unclear whether this is still on the
cards though in particular after NBC
canceled powerless a comedy set in the
DC Universe that explored a similar
premise about how ordinary people deal
with the fallout from superhero
activities we learn in homecoming that
Tony Stark has sold off Avengers Tower
and Manhattan Smith moving upstate to
the New Avengers facility can we get a
quick cameo by dummy one of Tony Stark's
to help a robot from the Iron Man movies
last seen
build up and being driven away by Tony
at the end of Iron Man 3 there's another
Iron Man Easter eggs thanks to the
design of the t-shirt Peter works when
he goes to see Tony Stark of the New
Avengers facility it has the exact same
science joke as the t-shirts at Pepper
Potts wore in Iron Man 3 which is
especially fitting as after Peter leaves
pepper emerges from the press conference
where she's been waiting for him by the
way the new suit that Tony shows Peter
in this scene is also an iced teas for
the iron spider costume comic book
artist Mark Bagley who's known Leah's
work on titles including the amazing
spider-man and ultimate spider-man gets
a shout out via graffiti on a building
in the background while Spidey's on the
phone to happy hogan following Tony
Stark and Aunt May's flirty first
meeting and Captain America Civil War
Tony continued his flirtation in
homecoming this time via video peter
shoots on his cellphone though may later
said she's not a fan of that Tony Stark
this is all a nod to Robert Downey jr.
and Marissa today's real-life
relationship in the 90s and also their
on-screen relationship in the rom-com
only you but Tony's not the only guy
enamored with may both the bodega owner
and the waiter at the Thai restaurant
feel the same way
all of which is a pointed contrast to
Mays previous movie and some of her
comic book incarnations Aunt May's joke
about his turkey meatloaf recipe is a
little callback to a humorous scene in
the first amazing spider-man movie where
Andrew Garfield's Peter Parker arrives
back home ravenous and eats art maze
Meat Loaf's declaring it's the best
meatloaf ever
and when mayim Peter go out for Thai
food right next door to the restaurant
there's a little nod to sort homeland
via the Korean Church of Asgard the work
of John Hughes with a particular
inspiration for homecoming director John
what and there are several moments in
the movie which reference classic films
by Hughes for example Zendaya's
character Michelle channel's Ally Sheedy
outcasts
character Allison from The Breakfast
Club and like Allison in the 1985
coming-of-age classic in homecoming
Michelle spends time and attention there
apparently she doesn't have to be there
and there are also a couple of Amara's
to the 1986 film Ferris Bueller's Day
Off as well first as a scene where Peter
races after shocker through a suburban
neighborhood Peter's run through Gardens
tossed barbecues dogs and children
is John watts his ode the classic teen
comedy by John Hughes where Ferris
Bueller had to race home to get there
before his family in fact we even see a
little clip of Faris's own race against
the clock on a big TV in one of the
gardens that Peter Parker rushes through
and Peter even says great movie as he
runs by the very final post-credit scene
featuring Captain America's humorous PSA
about the virtues of patience is a very
meta moment and joke by the filmmakers
to all of us in the audience you've
become accustomed to sitting through the
credits in any Marvel movie - the chance
to see a little tease - future MCU film
Captain America pokes Planet Earth with
the scene in a similar spirit the fourth
wall breaking joke in the post credits
of Ferris Bueller's Day Off which was of
course directly spoofed in 2016 Deadpool
so it was of course another after credit
scene which features a villain max
Gorgon and there's a cool teasers
comic-book alter-ego of the Scorpion fly
the scorpion tattoo on his neck the
scene sets of a much bigger role for
Gargan in the sequel and his mention of
having friends on the outside you want
to take out spider-man could be a tease
- the supervillain squads of sinister
six Home Coming already introduced three
characters who've been members of this
in assisting in the comics that vulture
Scorpion and shocker
so this is nicely halfway to a full
sinister six crew Sony has been hoping
to make a sinister six movie for a while
now and it's not hard to think that
these characters could be spun off
eventually into a separate movie so
listen reveal at the end of the movie by
Michelle's character is that her friends
called her MJ this feels like a bit of a
joke by the filmmakers about persistent
rumors during production that zendaya
was going to be playing Mary Jane it's
not actually a Mary Jane reveal because
all she's saying is that her nickname is
MJ even though Spidey fans around the
world will know that MJ is of course
synonymous with Mary Jane with the
filmmakers shying away from the moment
from using various characters from the
Sam Raimi trilogy and the amazing
spider-man movies it doesn't seem likely
that we'll see a real Larry Jane for a
while
of course Marvel might also try to find
a way to make Michelle into Mary Jane
with a trick like for example making
Mary Jane her middle name and therefore
the reason for MJ nickname very James
classic nickname of tiger for Peter
Parker gets some great visual shoutouts
at the high school via several home
manners includes the words tiger plus at
one point I also noticed someone in a
tiger costume running around the school
in the background face it tiger you just
hit the jackpot where Mary Jane's first
words to Peter Parker in the comics and
Kirsten Dunst MJ said go get em tiger to
Tobey Maguire's Peter at the very end of
spider-man 2 and to round off the very
self-aware nature of this spider-man
movie homecoming even integrated the
theme tune from the original 1960s
spider-man TV show into the opening
Marvel logo intro with a composition by
Michael chiquinho so what was your
favorite Easter Egg Roll moment and
spider-man homecoming and were there any
references I missed be sure to leave a
comment about the movie and subscribe
for a chance to win either a spider-man
Funko pop or some cool official
merchandise and announce the winners on
an upcoming video so make sure you've
got your notifications turned on to
receive all my new videos and if you
enjoyed this your support is really
appreciated so hit that thumbs up button
and check out some more videos you might
like here congratulations to the first
winner of my Wonder Woman giveaway whoo
when both the art and making of the film
and the official movie novelization if
you're the person on screen right now
send me a message on youtube or by my
email on my a bat page so I can send you
the prize thanks for watching and see
you next time you became movie lovers